anger engulfing the streets of Paris
once again
with an attack on a famous and favorite
Brasserie of the French president
amid clashes between protesters and
police
on the 11th day of Nationwide strikes
over pension reform plans to raise the
retirement age to 64.
[Music]
this is a regular snapshot of discontent
pervading much of France
talks between unions and the French
prime minister Elizabeth Bourne broke
down
they live in a parallel reality it's
incredible they have to stop thinking
that they can rewrite history and change
reality what happened is that
yesterday's meeting was a slap in the
face for the government we slapped the
door because Elizabeth Bond refused to
withdraw the reform we told her from one
voice that if this reform was not
withdrawn we could not talk about
anything else
macron's argument the country can't
afford the current pension system is
rejected on Mass foreign
Fury over a decision to force reform
through without a vote
we won't give up until they take the
time to listen until they reconsider
their decision We Won't Give Up
the Constitutional courts will rule on
the legality of legislation next week
until then a fierce dissent promises to
rage on Adele Robinson Sky News